or did what we're doing lordy I don't
know I'm thinking what should we do
[Music]
Salam alaikum warahmatullah better care
to brothers and sisters as you can see
I'm here with pappu
what does bubble mean oh nothing it's
just a nice cute name for me
where are you originally from a
Bangladeshi no let me guess
oh give me a clue give me a clue
Malaysian mmm Mauritius how do you know
your former is because that's me always
mate and I'll [ __ ] diver then I came to
you go have you been a British passport
yet what's that
you know British possible no I bought
receipt well you don't bring a face is
gonna be after you don't go passport I
wanna see v18 everything okay we're
gonna do today is we're going to go
through some basics basics of what
taking this yes why mine
what am i known for what do I do teach
me British bad news you want brain to me
about bridge yeah yeah we all do what is
that besides that what is my name
I need our what we're going to talk a
bit about Islamiyah okay so we're gonna
go through and maybe there's there might
be kids at home watching
yeah I'm trying say forget kids actually
there's a lot of Muslims I don't know
these basics okay anyways let's go
through do you know what's the five
pillars of Islam you don't know are you
serious so how you moving this weapon to
your hair you know the last time I told
you
cup on it yeah I wanted to look neat
yeah you're quite cool actually you know
your hair sticking out thank you thank
you thank you thank you yeah that's good
hopefully nobody will refuse him the
imitation look over oh what's that
a long story I'll tell you another day
let's learn the basics today okay okay
what is the first thing that a Muslim
should have on his tongue and believe in
his heart no no no you say it on your
tongue you believe it in your heart and
you put it into action with your limbs
oh it's the Shahada oh yeah so we
testify that there's nothing worthy of
worship except Allah subhana WA Ta'ala
and the Prophet Muhammad sallallaahu
salam is his final messenger perfect so
once we have that we're good to go
yes and this would this statement that
you said yeah will be one of the well
the most heaviest thing on the scale of
their judgement
yes kids know this and they implement
this and Muslims
this is above kids and Muslims out there
cause sadly a lot of people do say it
but they don't act upon it oh no at
least they know and hope is there act
upon it yeah yes good good would you be
happy then yes can you do you do like a
special dance I love you train is buddy
you got more stronger than me yeah yeah
we're gonna be friends okay can I hop
backwards yeah cause things are getting
a bit cool maybe both oh you look proper
cool you know there might be some
sisters watching maybe they want to get
married you know that
yeah oh no no I don't like it okay you
don't have to like okay okay okay we're
gonna get mad we're gonna come to that
but first first disability no you're not
alright because these sisters they want
a Muslim Bravo oh yeah good parts of
Muslim brother okay
okay so first when you're a Muslim and
you know the basic things then the
system I think you know what this
probably knows something
yeah okay now the second thing yeah yeah
is the most important thing is the Salah
oh yes the Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him said is the between us and the
non-muslims is the Salah that's what
differentiates between us and go for
yeah yeah so Salah is important how many
times do we pray I'm not just good
looking okay you're gonna call Shona
they're gonna be missing the third one
is the cat yes whose cap are you are you
taking Mikami no you said yeah yeah
you're gonna find out soon how dangerous
ham when I do it I'm gonna do box and
mushroom mohammadi job soon hmm
yeah do you know how many job No you'll
find out soon don't worry okay yeah yeah
yeah we okay the third is a cat yeah not
cut the cat the cat is okay yeah so
that's given 2.5 percent in charity why
do it even charity that's good so we
want to help people that less fortunate
but we actually help ourself more by
helping others because it'll be on our
scales under their judgment yes good
everything happy happy happy
yes good and the fourth is that we fast
in Ramadan yes I may need to be fast I'm
fasting all day all year round yes and
you're a life but you're not as lucky as
yeah I'm so quiet I just keep Boston
yeah
but Audrey yeah but the Prophet peace be
upon him said the one who is from me is
the one who follows my Sunnah meaning
the problem says sometimes I fall and
something sometimes some days I don't I
get married you know Salah yeah
so there's have it balanced yeah don't
okay violence yes and the last but not
least if you have the money
are you working yeah well find your job
okay okay I don't know what you're good
at but okay you got swagger may be
fashion yeah yeah okay cool
yeah the fifth is if you have the means
to okay and you're able to to perform
how did you I juice hard yeah
is it we go somewhere special yes
where's that to Makkah and you go to the
Kaaba and you do the obligatory things
so you're highly accepted and you cannot
argue and be talking about bison against
anyone you have to make sure that your
patient yes good that's good that's the
five pillars of Islam how about the six
articles of faith yes what do we have to
believe yes we believe in Allah etc but
okay what do you know the six articles
of faith okay the first one is that we
believe in Allah yes okay yes good the
second one is we believe in his angels
[Music]
we believe in angels we believe in his
messengers yes good and we believe in
the books that he sent yes we believe in
the day a judgment that's what we all
need to work for here the kids are
watching our home and the muslims we try
our best to offer it yes yeah yeah okay
and lastly but not least we believe in
the other color is the free destiny yeah
the good and the bad
okay of course even fix you fix it so
this is your
two eyes you know mmm yeah okay guys
that's it that's it don't be looking
anywhere okay that's the six yeah
articles of faith XA Mon yes so good so
these are the basic things that we all
have to know in it yes I'm so excited to
learn these things yes so guys if you
want us me and Babu to talk about more
stuff yes yes yes yes everybody yeah and
we're gonna do some serious topic yes
tell them to comment in the section
below what we do they want to see from
us yes till next time guys
assalamualaikum for me and Babu take it
back then